[Music]
with Dora where this fragrance of course
nothing else every hour every day
[Music]
today boss bottled it's not the sexiest
out of all the Hemsworth brothers what's
me cuz I'm melange with you got boss of
course the others you know knock alone
guys ok Siri your you smell the best it
smell the best I do now on the past but
yeah thanks to hear applause Leon posted
this amazing quote oh the other day of
him in his abs and those teeny tiny
shorts hi why we don't even know could
have felt like that felt like a light
front I know it drunken kind of post and
then the following morning's like I
didn't did I not
you can't believe that now I was like is
that intentional was it so no chance of
you doing that in your future all right
exactly are you guys competitive when it
comes to staying fit and and sport um
yeah in a fun way you know people trying
Paris offices like this is a vicious
kind of attention and competitiveness
and are you go that part and I didn't
and stuff which is not the case I mean
get us at home playing curricular
football or surfing or something in the
others there's a great rivalry there are
exactly 100 fun people not in not with
work
[Music]
you